[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zu salehs welt heute
gibt es ein leckeres süßes hefegebäck
und zwar mache ich buchteln viele kennen
sie auch unter dem namen buchteln finde
ich auch genial denn sie sind wirklich
wirklich genial wuchtig kenia wuchteln
eigentlich komisch egal
oder sie sind auch bekannt als rodeln
oder ofen nudeln nudeln das ist ein
hefeteig gebäck aus hefeteig hat eine
richtig tolle füllung innen drin und ich
werde das ganze heute servieren mit
einer kirche als er mit seiner kirche
ich habe es hier mit zwei verschiedenen
füllungen zubereitet einmal mit mohn das
ist so mein liebling einmal mit nougat
von murat aber ich kenne sie auch mit
aprikosenmarmelade oder mit kirsch
marmelade
da sind sie auch wirklich super lecker
und vor allem sehr saftig ich sag jetzt
erst einmal die zutaten für den hefeteig
denn damit geht's los für den hefeteig
brauche ich einen würfel hefe etwas
vanille exakt 80 gramm zucker 2
esslöffel warmes wasser einen teelöffel
salz 1 eigelb 200 milliliter milch die
habe ich ein bisschen erwärmt 80 gramm
butter dies bereits flüssig ab rät von
einer unbehandelten zitrone und 500
gramm
zuerst nehme ich jetzt das wasser und
die hefe und die hefe bietet darin
aufgelöst
und da wo ich jetzt kleine gruppe ist an
der zucker mit rein
bisschen
[Musik]
ich gebe ich die mischung in eine große
schüssel und den teig könnte jetzt
entweder mit den händen verkneten oder
einfach mit der küchenmaschine jetzt
kommen im prinzip einfach die restlichen
zutaten mit dazu das heißt restlicher
zucker extrakt seien ebenfalls schlecht
drauf ich meine liegt in der hand als
geht muss schon wieder besser ich glaube
das hat den ganzen tag gewählt
mai gilt
damit die mädels und jetzt lebe ich
schon mal mehr rein fabrik von der
zitrone und jetzt noch die flüssige
butter und dann werde ich den teig in
sieben bis zehn minuten zu einem
geschmeidigen teig verkneten
[Musik]
der hefeteig ist durchgeknetet jetzt
verspricht die arbeitsfläche mit etwas
baktrien stream und auch die händler
müssen da klebt zwar nicht ist trotzdem
besser
jetzt kann ich den hier rausholen zu
einer kugel formen geht ihnen dann
wieder in die schüssel zurück und dann
dafür abgedreht war eine stunde rum
[Musik]
jetzt ist der hefeteig aufgegangen und
ich kann die buchteln jetzt formen für
den rat werde ich ein paar mit nougat
befüllen für mich werde ich ein paar mit
mohn befüllen und ich zeige euch hier
nochmal die zutaten für die mundspülung
brauche ich 50 mm 143 gramm zucker etwas
vanille extrakt eine prise salz und zehn
gramm butter für die mundspülung gebe
ich jetzt zuerst einmal sind milch in
einem topf dazu kommt auch dass zucker
butter und salz und aufwand extrakt und
die zutaten werden erwärmen
das heißt die milch kurz aufkochen
lassen natürlich unter aufsicht und in
der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon
mal den mund nehmen und fein mahlen und
falls sie jetzt keine mühle habt findet
morgen könnt ihr auch bereits bemalen
oder auch nur fertige mond backmischung
nehmen
[Musik]
die mischung dürfte jetzt einmal
aufkochen den herd habe ich jetzt
abgestellt
jetzt kommen der mond wird damit dazu
mit eingeführt und dann kann ich das
ganze so 10 bis 15 minuten ruhen lassen
und in der zwischenzeit schon mal den
teig port zu werden
[Musik]
die arbeitsfläche bespricht mit extras
was prinz tray und da kommt jetzt der
teig drauf und je nach backformen und
erst recht schön richtig schöner tag und
je nach backform können dir jetzt 16
oder auch 15 machen weil es die backform
schwindelig ist mache ich jetzt 15
punkten also drei reihen a5 und den teig
portioniert nicht einfach so ich teile
die nicht in 16 teile und teilt dann ist
ein stück noch die restlichen auf oder
ihr könnt ihr noch einfach abwägen und
abmessungen
[Musik]
und die habe ich jetzt einfach zu
kleinen kugeln
[Musik]
diese kugeln nämlich ist und werde jetzt
leicht öffnen jetzt nicht zu weit
denn so einfach mal noch mehr
verschließen das heißt gerade zur hand
groß ungefähr
jetzt kommt staaten bis zur verfüllung
rein ich fange jetzt einmal mit der mond
füllung an
und die können ja auch wirklich mit
allem berühren also pflaumen sind auch
wirklich so verleger marmelade ist total
lecker und da nehme ich jetzt die seiten
und packt es jetzt so wieder zusammen
und drückte es praktisch mit den fingern
zusammen als ich verschließe die nähte
und sobald das fest zusammen ist drehe
ich es um und kann jetzt wieder eine
schöne kugel formen
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich noch die variante für
murat mit nougat wobei was heißt im
monat ich geb dir natürlich auch sehr
und dafür nicht einfach einen ukas
stange kann die portionieren und die
dann genau durch
[Musik]
die buchteln habe ich jetzt meine
backformen reingesetzt und die habe ich
vorher mit back transfer eingestellt
jetzt war diese noch mit flüssiger
butter bestreichen
[Musik]
jetzt können wir die bösen entweder
abdecken und noch mal eine halbe stunde
aufgehen lassen oder ihr macht so wie
ich werde jetzt in einen kalten backofen
schieben und dann den backofen auf 180
grad ober unterhitze stellen und wir
brauchen diese etwa 30 bis 40 minuten
ist einfach schauen dass er an der
oberfläche schwimmen konnte während die
buchteln jetzt gerade noch packen werde
ich schon mal eine kirsch füllung
zubereiten und zeige ich hier fordern
die zutaten für die kirche brauche ich
ein glas kirschen da habe ich bereits
den saft aufgefangen also die kirschen
abtropfen lassen
40 gramm zucker 20 kampfstärke etwas
mannel extrakt und ein bisschen abrieb
von der unbehandelten zitrone und auch
ein bisschen zitronensaft jetzt geht das
ganze ziemlich schnell ich gebe dir den
kirschsaft einfach in einen topf da
kommen die zitronenschale und ein
bisschen zitronensaft dazu dann nehmt
ihr einfach so viel wie er gerne möchte
ich nehme es den saft von der halben
zitrone und bevor das ganze heiß wird
auch die stärke und den zucker und das
kann ich jetzt schön glatt rühren und
dann auch kochen lassen
[Musik]
sobald die soße kocht gebe ich jetzt die
kirschen mediation und lasst das ganze
einfach bei mittlerer stufe ein bisschen
ein kochen bis die gewünschte konsistenz
erreicht ist nach dem backen betreue ich
die buchteln noch mit dekor schnee
das ist ein extra feiner puderzucker der
auf der oberfläche nicht schmilzt und
perfekt zu den buchteln passt
[Musik]
jetzt darf der murat die buchteln
wuchteln probieren und ich hab sie noch
mit dem schnee bestreiten wir haben ja
einst mit nougat das hat aber auch schon
etliche 50 50-chance ich habe entweder
die drei hier mit nokia teurer die drei
aber ich tippe auf dem ok und die
buchteln müsste immer frisch essen ist
ein richtig cool diesen ungefähr
ich werde am nächsten tag sonst kann man
ja noch cool essen gerade sind andere
lecker aber ich finde man muss am
gleichen tag noch ist also normalerweise
ist du locker 56 stück am tag näher
definierte ihr könnt wo alles ist so
lecker und wenn dann richtig liegt also
wir sehen jetzt nicht von außen aber
darf ich dir trotzdem ein bisschen von
der kirche okay geben
ok cool
das ist ja mal wo ich glaube dass so
heißen die luft oder ist sie so
schachteln natürlich erst mit ihr so
madonna ganz lecker einfach nur gehen ja
also ich finde die war schon genial also
das ist echt der hammer kalt kann ich es
auch essen aber warum jetzt so hinsetzen
mit dem ganzen pott und vom fernseher
das war natürlich mein absoluter
programm glas wasser ja ich glaube auch
kaum kalorien denn die sind ja bei 180°
gebacken
ich glaube dass in alle kalorien
verbrannt vor allem die blue card die
butter bestimmt anders
das ist der wahnsinn wie luftdicht gerne
japan sicherheit gemacht habe ich habe
die nicht ganz normal gebacken also alle
gesten das habe ich dir schon
zubereitete ganz normal gebacken und
heute habe ich sogar mit dampf gebacken
weil dadurch die oberfläche trocken
nicht so aus und dann wird die
oberfläche auch kann ja wohl auch
gemerkt man muss erst mal funktioniert
ja ich halte ich weder zu reich stoßen
und wie gesagt die künste mit kirschen
essen also einer die kirschen neben
teller legen und dann halt ich kenne die
mannschaft sich die muster aufweisen
ich würde die quoten ein als er jetzt
auch lust bekommen habt auf diese
leckeren buchteln dann schaut auf meinem
blog auf 6 - blog.de vorbei da steht
noch mal alles ganz genau für euch und
ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei und ich
freue mich jetzt schon auf meiner
position das ist echt bis zum echten
buchteln januar herum ja aber ich muss
machen also bis zum nächsten mal süß von
lecker geld und normalerweise mochte
stören nichts süßes und warmes aber
leider mich kennt mag das alles private
mit einem ring geschmack und das ist
jetzt geschäft er sagt doch immer privat
ist er nichts ist es nicht okay aber
wahnsinnig superbike super genial
jetzt kann man da auch mal ist er den
puderzucker weg nach oben oder auch mal
herzhaft
wir machen zb ein bisschen hammermäßig
und dem man halt machte
[Musik]
jetzt ist der hefeteig auf
gegangen und ich kann die buchteln jetzt
formen für den rat werde ich ein paar
mit mohn befüllen
nein genau andersherum